okay so today I am going to show you an
absolutely outrageous and baseless
Donald Trump line but I'm gonna do
something else I'm gonna show you the
genesis of the lie I'm gonna show you
the evolution of the lie how it becomes
more and more dishonest over time and we
in a sense to quote Donald Trump we're
going to look at the oranges of this lie
or as I like to call them the origins of
this lie so Donald Trump spoke yesterday
I believe it was maybe it was late on
Monday and it was complete diarrhea of
the mouth I mean just endless lie after
lie after lie I'll give you the most
sort of cartoonish lie first which we'll
be focusing on which is that when Donald
Trump became president the military was
out of ammunition I know that may come
as a surprise to many of you in the
audience who are aware of how much money
we spend on the military but Trump's
claim is the military had no ammunition
when he became president but he fixed
that take a look at this I we all
together you we defeated and took over
100 percent of the Isis Caliphate
everybody said that was going to be an
impossible thing to do I did it and I
did it quickly because we have a great
military now when I took over a military
we didn't have ammunition I was told by
a top general maybe the top of them all
sir I'm sorry sir we don't have
ammunition I said I'll never let another
president have that happen to him or her
we didn't have ammunition
now we've captured Isis we've done what
we've done we had 50 soldiers in the
area you're talking about by the way no
one said it would be impossible to
defeat Isis that that's like another lie
when the when the Obama administration
was getting ready to exit I said many
many times and so did others that we are
sort of on a trajectory for at least
with regard to its territory the
Caliphate is some like to call it of
Isis we are heading towards the
destruction of that the question will be
how do we deal with radicalized cells
that are disconnected but whether it was
Hillary or Trump what Trump is talking
about the elimination of the Caliphate
was likely to happen either way I said
it many people said it but Trump says we
had
no ammunition when he became president
he fixed it and now lo and behold we
have captured Isis we'll get back to
that that's the lie I will show you the
evolution of but a few other choice lies
by Donald Trump from this very strange
speech Donald Trump claiming of course
with no evidence that his poll numbers
are up 17 points in the last three days
now when he says his poll numbers does
he mean hypothetical 2020 polling does
he mean approval polling we never know
and of course the reason we never know
is because it is made-up he has nothing
to back this up it's obviously untrue
this is a scam and the people of wires
to it and that's why my polls weren't up
I think they said 17 points in the last
two or three days I've never had that
one yes so no I mean that just it didn't
happen and then here is Donald Trump
saying total falsehoods about Adam
Schiff these are even less coherent like
these are it's more difficult to even
understand what allegations Trump is
making here but they're all very much
untrue take a look Adam Schiff should be
investigated for what he did he took to
the great chamber Congress and he made a
speech and his speech was a fraud
everything he said was a fraud he went
out as though I wrote it he defrauded
the American people he defrauded
Congress he defrauded himself and his
family he made a speech as with a
horrible speech I said what does this
gut what's going on here I think he's
having some kind of a breakdown because
he got up and made a speech that bore no
relationship to what the conversation
was you can tell Trump is kind of making
it up as he goes along and none of that
stuff is true so let's go back now to
the ammunition claim let's look at the
oranges of this lie where did Donald
Trump's lie that the military was out of
ammunition
until Trump fixed it come from to begin
with this is the genesis of that lie the
evolution of the bogus story I think
you'll find this interesting so of
course it's not true that the Year Trump
became president the US military was out
of an
in 2016 the u.s. spent more than 600
billion dollars on the military much of
that went to ammunition we had plenty of
ammunition already although it is true
that Barack Obama had slightly trimmed
the amount of military spending in some
areas okay so Donald Trump's story
started with way back then when I met
with general mattis he came to me and he
said we are low on ammo now we don't
even know if that's true right it's
possible that it's totally made-up it's
possible that mattis went to trump and
said listen we are behind on the
accumulation of a certain type of
ordnance it may not even have been again
if it's true it may not even have been
because Barack Obama wasn't spending
enough money it may have been a supply
issue it could have been who knows right
but it started with mattis cam to me and
said we are low on ammo Trump has then
exploded the military budget so it's
probably true that Donald Trump has
spent a lot more money on ammunition
Trump took that story which may have a
kernel of truth in it or it may not like
we don't even know and then expanded the
lie to say well mattis said we have low
/no ammunition okay that was he modify
always has to go to the next step here's
Trump expanding it too it wasn't just
low it was low slash no ammunition for
the first time today a general came into
my office and my first few weeks you
remember was a little dangerous out
there
President Obama left us with a few
beauties right
and I said to this general you better be
prepared because this is looking like it
could really be conflict and he looked
at me and he goes sir we have very
little ammunition I said say it again
and I want to tell you the words very
little he didn't use because it was less
than that and I said I never want to see
a president in a position like that well
we may have conflict and a general looks
at him and said we have very little / no
ammunition I never want a President of
the United States to be in that position
okay so mattis supposedly saying we are
low we don't even know if that's true
becomes mattis said we are low / out of
ammunition okay this is the first
evolution of this lie then four days
later Donald Trump upgrades to we had no
ammunition at all I've rebuilt the
military we've Scott and I were talking
about that we spend one and a half
trillion dollars when I came in our
military was depleted frankly we didn't
have ammunition okay but our military
was in very bad shape and then now in
about a one month period it all becomes
we had no ammo and I fixed it I got us
ammo and because of that I was able to
defeat the Caliphate of Isis in the
Middle East when again the colonel of
possible truth is maybe mattis said we
were low possibly about some particular
kind of ammunition unclear if it's
because of anything Barack Obama had
done right could have been a supply
issue could have been anything and that
possible kernel of truth becomes Trump
endlessly repeating that we had no
ammunition and he got us ammunition and
that's the ammunition that was read by
the way ammunition right I mean like
what an unsophisticated term to even be
using that is the ammunition that got us
the defeat of the Caliphate of Isis in
the Middle East thanks to the great lord
and savior donald trump the genesis of a
lie
okay understand how it works these
people will stop at nothing he will say
anything it doesn't matter whether it
has a grain of truth a kernel of truth
or not question for you do you believe
that Donald Trump has convinced himself
that the latest most extreme version of
the story is true or do you think that
Trump knows that he is exaggerating this
story which possibly is not based in any
actual reality let me know i'm on
instagram at D Pakman the show is on
Instagram at David Pakman show